هذه هي الطريقة التي بدأ بها الأسبوع الرابع من انتفاضة إيران ،
وقد كسبت الحيتان المزيد من العائلات
إلى الأبد وداعًا لحياة شابة أخرى
سلبت في وقت قريب جدًا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
إحدى الأرواح العديدة التي فقدت في يوم
غضب يوم من المذبحة في المنطقة الكردية بإيران
[تصفيق]
] ولذا فإن الصور التي لا
يريد النظام أن يراها العالم
تقطع الإنترنت في سان أندرياس
مما يجعل من الصعب علينا سرد
قصص الموتى وأولئك الذين تُركوا
للحزن
[تصفيق
] الفيديو الصغير الذي يتدفق فقط
لمحة عن الجمهورية القمعية
وقوتها الشريرة لسحق الوحشية المتزايدة التي تم
التقاطها بالكاميرا في مشاهد مثل
هذه في
طهران وهذا رجل يناشد الشرطة
لترك زوجته وشأنها نحن لا
نحتج على أنها حامل ، كما يقول ولكن
دون جدوى.  يبدو أنه قد تم
جره بالقوة ،
فهذا الاستبداد هو الذي يغذي
غضب أولئك في الشوارع الذين يتحدون
ويصممون على ما يبدو. أنت
تطارد شرطة مكافحة الشغب
[تصفيق]
في جامعة نسائية بالكامل
الجاذبية في نهاية هذا الأسبوع ، الرئيس إبراهيم رئيسي الذي
طرد الآلاف في الشوارع
حيث يثني الكتاب على الطلاب
لرؤية ما يزعم أنه مؤامرة أجنبية
لإضعاف إيران في نفس
الجامعة لحظة غير عادية من
التمرد حيث
تضيع البطلة الشابة جرايسي
[تصفيق]
من غير الواضح ما إذا كان هذا قد حدث أثناء وجوده
هناك ما هو واضح هو أن جدار الخوف
في إيران قد انهار
حتى أن محاولة النظام للسيطرة على
السرد تعطلت أيضًا لفترة وجيزة قراصنة
قطعوا التلفزيون الرسمي مساء السبت
نشرة الأخبار مع هذا الفيديو هدف
فرض على وجه الأعلى.
زعيم وفي اسفل
الشاشة وجوه ماساجينا اميني وثلاث
من الشابات اللواتي لقين حتفهن في
الاحتجاج نيكا شكارامي هادس النجفي
وسيرينا اسماعيل زاده برسالة
تقرأ انضموا إلينا
وانهضوا شوارع طهران بالفعل
انتفضت تلك الليلة مع بعض
أكبر الاحتجاجات في العاصمة حتى الآن
مشاهد متكررة في جميع أنحاء البلاد مثل
t  تزعم الحكومة أن الهدوء قد
عاد وأن أعمال الشغب المزعومة تحدث في
الغالب خلال
النهار مما أدى إلى عودة المزيد من الطلاب
بقوة للاحتجاج في الجامعات في جميع
أنحاء البلاد
والتلاميذ الصغار يلوحون
بأوشحة أيديهم القسرية للانضمام إلى الهتافات الجريئة
[تصفيق]
صرخاتهم الجريئة من أجل  حياة المرأة
يتردد صداها أعلى من أي وقت مضى
في شوارع إيران
[موسيقى].